cette année le siège de sexo France fait
pe neuve après 18 mois de travaux
l'entreprise inaugurée mardi 17 octobre
son nouvel environnement de travail son
nom la maison Sodexo 18000 m²
entièrement rénové qui a un objectif se
sentir comme à la maison on s'adapte au
mode hybride de du nouvel environnement
c'est-à-dire que les gens travaillent 3
jours par semaine ici au bureau et 2
jours chez eux donc quand ils viennent
ici ce qu'ils recherchent c'est des
espaces de collaboration des salles de
réunions des espaces aussi de
convivialité donc ce qu'il recherche et
l'interaction pour faciliter ses
échanges Sodexo a donc doublé ses salles
de réunion les espaces du bureau se
veulent confortables le principe faire
en sorte que le salarié se déplace en
fonction des tâches qu'il a à effectuer
par exemple sur les plateaux on va
trouver donc on est en open space son
des open space pas trop grand à taille
humaine pour être convivial
chaleureux et en fait on a un nombre
important de bulles de une de 3 enfin de
capacités varié en fait pour que les
gens puissent s'isoler ou se réunir au
contraire le but c'est vraiment
de que les gens en fait puissent
travailler confortablement au
rez-de-chaussée de nouveaux espaces ont
été créés le tout dans un décor de
village une conciergerie un pressing ou
encore un coffee shop ont été mise en
place pour les salariés pour ce qui est
de la restauration Sodexo a mis les
petits plats dans les grands on a
diversifier en fait notre offre de
restauration on a un restaurant
d'entreprise mais on a aussi un coffee
shop qui est ouvert une bonne part de la
journée dont l'offre évolue au fil de la
journée et on a aussi après un corner
food
cher où là les gens en fait peuvent
commander leur repas déguster une offre
différente donc on a en fait trois
offres on a une offre diversifiée et
plurielle pour satisfaire un maximum de
convivre avec ce réaménagement Sodexo
France peut maintenant accueillir 1200
personnes sur son